the president flatly denied that he made
the comments that were attributed to him
via French official on the dollar that
was a clear of denial that the president
can say he said don't believe in onymous
sources and that he makes a practice out
of not commenting on daily fluctuations
of currency however he didn't say he
doesn't comment on currency altogether
that was the one thing I heard in there
is that he had he couched it with daily
fluctuations of currency it's possible
within the context of President Barack
Obama's denial that he was talking about
the longer-term trends of both the euro
and the dollar which of course it's
well-known does affect macro economic
forecasts so that would be the one edge
of the one caveat I would place on his
denial there other important thing the
president said he talked about the need
for flexibility on Greece and he talked
about the importance for all the
creditors to understand the hardship of
the Greek people remember this is a
country the latest unemployment we got
was at twenty five point six percent if
anything I heard the president softening
his stance on Greece or at least towards
the Greek side of thing and maybe urging
creditors to be a little more flexible a
little more forgiving and stores the
creditors are being led by Germany the
host country for this g7 summit Hans
compare and contrast the president's
tone on greece with what Angela Merkel
said at her news conference
there's not a lot of daylight between
the two of them they're both talking
about urgency they're both talking about
time running out that's been fairly
similar at least for the past four weeks
so you have to discount any EU statement
you get on urgency and time running out
where Merkel Gables showed a little bit
more just gave us a little bit more
information she confirmed a Wednesday
meeting with mr. tsipras that will be on
the sidelines of a Latin American summit
but there's another chance for political
leaders to get together sorry if you
can't hear me right now the helicopters
are flowing flying low overhead one
final note on Greece earlier day mr.
Yanis varoufakis speaking in berlin
giving an interview to a German
newspaper seemed to suggest that they
flat-out rejected the latest i am a
proposal the latest creditor proposal so
they have a lot of work to do on greece
and at least both sides seem to be
positioning themselves quite far away
what you heard President Obama saying is
that for the sake of the global economy
they need to come together and be
flexible and get this done